and the day that I was on set they were
testing makeup on you Prosthetics the
these like Prosthetics to make you look
more like Kim Jong-un and they were like
they really just don't work you just
have to gain weight yeah well they never
told me that they like if you want you
can gain we I had like two weeks from
the nixing that those Prosthetics to my
first day of shooting eat and I see
Randall for the first time in months hey
man how's it going like you really did
like put on some weight for this like
how do you feel and he looks me dead in
the eye and goes I feel awful I I did it
in the most unhealthy
way and I felt terrible yeah was there
was there a staple there was no no
thought it was just just pounding
whatever everything everything that I
wanted which was the worst of
consistently so you enjoyed the eating
you just hated it felt terrible it felt
terrible it felt the binging was
probably fun cuz you probably never that
was fun